jimbo
you are
and will always be
a global phenomenon
we need to stop meeting like this i am
completely shook
shooketh i am pissed off i'm gonna say
it i'm gonna put it out there i am
pissed oh my god dallas i love when
you're mad you're so handsome
oh that furrowed brow i feel completely
loved i feel seen by the world i feel
supported
um by the skimpy little bikini and by
all the love around the world i'll get
you rue
and your little dog too
i'm talking about you michelle
the truth is something was not right
there i think juju was playing a very
brilliant game because listen i would do
the exact same thing you did you were
just feeling things out would you keep
me if
i kept you she took advantage of knowing
that they're a bunch of dumb and she put
a little seed of doubt in her head and
of course they all started oh oh oh and
it's like girl there's two lipsticks
okay
you only have a 50 50 chance of pissing
someone off i think that michelle is
right i think you're not quite here yet
you said it herself she just could have
tried harder the judges were saying it
too jujube is my sister she is such i'm
a huge fan of ggb i was just feeling it
out and i was asking the question that
everybody asked which is if you say if i
save you will you save me and they were
just jealous they were just jealous and
i don't want anyone to send pangina any
kind of hate however i do think pangina
made a mistake
and i want to know where does your
relationship stand now with tangina
you know pangina messaged me before my
interviews today she said that i was so
beautiful
so talented she said i was so funny so
charismatic
and that she was just really jealous of
my
interactions with rue that she really
wished that she could have had those
interactions that she admired my comedic
timing that she loved the looks i was
serving and she really just said that i
was her biggest competition and that she
decided to get rid of me and so you know
what no one can blame her for doing that
that's how the game is played so in your
mind who should have went home instead
of the iconic drag clown jimbo well i
think looking at that when i watched it
back
i definitely i love vega but i did think
their wig was not on properly
i
i guess it was you know
there was a lot of sort of
problems leading up to that performance
with her attitude her sort of take on
the whole shebangs i think she maybe
should have been in the bottom i also
think mo i love the concept i love the
look but then with that little shoddy
cardigan
um
everything being a slippery sloppy and
then that weird little cartwheel moment
again
that was a little bit jiggity yankity it
just
i i was a bit confused about why i would
all of a sudden end up in the bottom
what did it mean to have somebody an
icon like rupaul
watch your drag which really is unlike
anybody else out there and appreciate
and respect what you did on that stage i
am blown away by this outfit and i loved
your act it really showed me you know we
had a lot of interactions that obviously
weren't shown on the show but she really
let me know that she saw me as a person
with a history she knew about my life
story which is a very complicated life
story with a lot of drama and a lot of
sadness a lot of pain and so she loves
that i fearlessly and generously share
my story through my art and so i think
she just appreciated me as a human being
and also
saw who i am as an entertainer and as a
performer on her show mom are you hungry
[Music]
[Applause]
oh hey there if you want more lgbtq news
and exclusive interviews click subscribe
or watch these videos